Hãy bỏ kẻng giám chanh dấu Mỹ, SRL và Yvang Lăn, San Nguồn, Sá Lăn Cận,
nhiều nước đã tinh hoạt kế hoàn bảo hộ vừa dí tàn tuần hơn khỏi khu bực trung đông.
Chính của anh cho biết đánh thử kiện chiến sịch lãnh sợ lớn nhất lịch sử đơn nước.
Khi số công dân mắt kẻ tại Trung đông là hai chăm nghìn người,
có phương gà nâng được xem xét bóng của vận chuyển công dân bằng xe biết,
từ khu vực vực vực vực vực vực tựa cất sân bây tại Rập xíu.
Phóng zí chuyển bằng đu viện tới, còn hoa xíp.
Ngà tổ chức dí tàn cho khoảng lắm trong công dân đang chờ dời khỏi Yvang qua zi bài dân.
Trung khi bà lăn thí là bự dây ngống và quyến cáo công dân dời khu vực khi điều kiện cho phép.
Con tại trộ á, nhà bản thân báo trình bị phương án vận chuyển công dân từ SRL bằng xe biết,
nhưng chưa có lộ chính cuộc thay.
Trung Quốc cho biết đã đưa khoảng 3 il người dời khỏi Yvang và tăng tưởng hữu chở tại các cửa khẩu.
Người phân ngôn bộ mọi rời trung buông hào nguyên ngày 11,8, cũng chưa biết thêm.
Đại có một công dân Trung Quốc hiệp mạng tại trường lúc tại Héran, Zor của tấn công.
Trung khi đó, thái lăn cũng sẽ dừng kẻ hoa gí chuyển công dân mà lộ bộ sang thủ như khi,
bởi khoảng cách ra 1 lìm thương mếp trước khi nỗi trường bài về nước,
như cũng ra khá cũng phải đi cạnh báo đi lại,
nhận mạnh tình hình ảnh nền có thể dị biến phút tạm và các tiê hoa gí tàn sẽ tiếp tục được điều trình theo thực tế.